so this one is really wild so Pete
bootage Edge and as you know Pete
bootage Edge is our transportation
secretary with no expertise in
transportation mayor of South Bend
Indiana no offense to South Bend small
town maybe a hundred thousand people I'm
not even sure if it's that many he had
absolutely no expertise in this but Pete
is married to a dude thus he gets a
better job
that's kind of how it works that's what
they do that's what they promote they
love diversity Equity inclusion doesn't
matter if you're good at what you do how
many lesbians do we have in here how
many black people do we have here that's
what they love so uh Pete was being
interviewed uh and listen to his
priorities what is most important to
Pete more than anything else this is
really this is wild imagine if you ever
said anything like this
climate climate is not nonsense dealing
with climate change is one of the
biggest things that people like me and
people like him will be remembered for
after we're gone
let's put aside your feelings on climate
for just a second now I think it's 99
climate change I think is 99 complete
nonsense meaning the climate is always
changing humans figure out different
places to live we adapt we move we build
different structures Etc et cetera we
know all the Democrats the rich
Democrats like Obama Martha's Vineyard
on the water Pelosi on the water this is
what they do okay fine but he's mostly
thinking about what his legacy will be
how he will be remembered and if you
think for one second that AOC or Pete
bootage can stop or adjust Mother Nature
you are crazy these people these people
can't do anything they they actually
well they can't do anything good they
can't create anything good which is why
they've never created a business they've
never created a sustainable entity that
has employed a whole bunch of people and
helped a bunch of people flourish what
they are good at is taking money from
some people and just pushing it towards
other people and usually keep keeping
them in poverty or something like that
but he's mostly thinking about that if
he can get this done related to climate
change whatever this is right we don't
even know what this is you want aoc's
green New Deal or whatever it is that
that's what he will be remembered by
it's just it was like gross listening to
it and that that's what you it's not up
to you to decide what you will be
remembered by I I don't know I don't
know if anyone's going to remember me I
had a little Adventure here it was a
little blip in the in the radar of the
universe and uh if I'm remembered it'll
be up to somebody else not uh not up to
me uh but they seem to care about their
looks right that's what Laurie she had
to break the laws of covid because she
cares about how she looks and Pete has
to care about his legacy
of course his Legacy isn't looking so
great because he's always complaining
about uh fossil fuels all of that stuff
but he does like the private jet because
he's a Democrat he's better than you
there is an internal audit of your use
of FAA jets for official trips following
a request for review by Senator Marco
Rubio it also his scrutinized Elaine
child's private jet uh travel as
Transportation secretary do you have a
response to that
yeah here's how we handle my travel the
vast majority of the time I travel on
commercial airlines and economy class
but there is a portion of the time I'd
say about 10 to 20 percent uh when we
use our agency's aircraft this is not
chartering a private jet this is a
government aircraft that is assigned to
the FAA
uh yeah it's private though right
meaning you're the guy that gets on the
plane and there's a pilot and you got
your couple people that work for you and
you do your thing
I'm not against that I'm just calling
out your ridiculous hypocrisy
[Music]